hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
kochwelt heute gibt es mal wieder was
leckeres türkisches und zwar werde ich
einen berg machen und jetzt fragen sich
wahrscheinlich viele was ist für dich
oder viele denken sich ok aber was will
ich machte das ist nämlich einfach so
ein ausdruck für ganz viele teig
gerichte und das kann man wirklich auf
ganz verschiedene art und weisen machen
ich werde jetzt heute aus super machen
und nehmen auch fertigen youth pipe man
kann aber auch zum beispiel selber
machen aber das ist so ein blitz rezept
also das kann er machen wenn wir
unerwartet gäste bekommt und deswegen
benutze ich heute fertige juka blätter
macht dann eine vegetarische füllung
dazu und das besondere ist wir werden
das ganze dann einfach in der pfanne
backen und zwar auf einmal und dann
haben wir gleich ein richtig leckeres
gericht
und hier stehen jetzt meine zutaten
schauen ich habe cellulite jetzt könnt
ihr euch entscheiden ob ihr jetzt diese
hier nehmt das sind so dreieckige oder
ob ihr die hier nimmt die hatte ich mal
bei meinem baklava video benutzt und
zwar sind es rechteckige große und ich
werde es einfach gleich noch entscheiden
welche ich nehmen wobei ich glaube ich
die großen nehmen und die anderen
einfach aufhebt und daraus mal so kleine
zigarren rx macht die gibt es übrigens
in türkischen supermärkten oder auch
teilweise schon in deutschen
supermärkten also da müsste einfach mal
im kühlregal schauen da stehen die
meistens drin dann für die füllung
benutze ich etwas schafskäse das ist
auch ein echter schafskäse und zwar
benutze ich etwa zwei bis 400 gramm eine
stange lauch die habe ich jetzt bereits
gewaschen und zwar habe ich einfach
halbiert und dann müsste einfach so die
einzelnen blätter abnehmen und zwischen
rhein eben auch waschen weil er oft ganz
viel sand drinsteckt für den geschmack
brauche ich noch ein bisschen petersilie
und dann brauche ich noch so eine art
flüssigkeit und die mache ich aus einer
halben tasse olivenöl einem glas
mineralwasser also spröde und einem glas
milch habe ich so schnell geredet dass
sie außer puste bin aber alles gut
jetzt mache ich zuerst mal die füllung
und nehmen einfach die petersilie und
sagte klein
und ich habe jetzt einfach so mit
petersilie und im prinzip kann man da
auch gar nicht so genaue mengenangaben
machen weil es kommt darauf an was
pfanne er benutzt ich bin jetzt einfach
eine ganz normale teflon pfanne mit
beschichtung den tag legt dann auch
gleich nicht dran an ohne zweiten die
petersilie blätter einfach feiern gehabt
mein mann hat übrigens ich hab mir ein
bisschen petersilie mit und aussieht
schon er hat mir ein bisserl petersilie
mitgebracht es muss den rest eben auch
hacken und dann kann ich das einfrieren
und einfach bei bedarf rausholen und
besitzen ein halbes bund hat gereicht so
ich nehme da jetzt auch mit alles sind
nämlich alles voller petersilie
aber ich versuche es jetzt einfach so
klein wie möglich zu halten
und dann kommt es einfach in so ein
kleines schälchen wo ich das dann gleich
vermischen kann so ich glaube auch schon
zu viel gibt es jetzt einfach weg dann
kann es wie gesagt einfrieren und dann
eben wieder bin und jetzt nämlich auch
hier meine stange lauch und dann nehme
ich jetzt auch nur die halbe denn ich
will ja dass auch viel käse mit rich und
deswegen dürfen einsatz viel gemüse
nehmen statt des laufs könnte zum
beispiel auch frühlingszwiebeln in das
geht auch gut
gut kommt jetzt auch mit zur brasilien
ich finde der lauf gibt dem ganzen so
ein bisschen
diese würze und einfach so die betriebe
note und jetzt kann ich auch schon
meinen feta-käse nehmen und stehen hier
einmal aufschneiden und es ist jetzt
schon richtig würziger
also ich habe oft stehen auf der großen
dose aber das ist auch eine schöne
kleine packung vor allem für diejenigen
diesem große so eine große packung leer
bekommen
es hat echt eine super alternative und
sich auch der lieblings käse für murat
und den bröselig jetzt einfach so bitte
mit den händen da rein und damit alles
vermischt
ich habe jetzt hier noch die hälfte des
zweiten käses mit dazu gegeben also sind
es 300 gramm käse und es ist soweit
fertig kann ich einfach stehen lassen
und kann jetzt schon mal die füllung
zubereiten will oder reaktive
flüssigkeit und nehmen dafür jetzt mai
und das verquere ich jetzt hier mit
schneebesen einfach dass es gleich in
der flüssigkeit auflöst oder vermisst
besser kann als katholik besser besser
gesagt jetzt kommt dann noch das master
mit rein und die milch sieht jetzt alles
noch ziemlich viel aus aber und die
flüssigkeit eben auf das öl aber die
tagblatt dass er relativ trocken und
deswegen ist man da jetzt einfach wieder
so viel volk machen und einfach so
physiker zu geben so und im prinzip
haben jetzt schon die ganze arbeit
gemacht jetzt kann ich nämlich rüber zu
einer pfanne und die sitzt noch aus als
sie dies nicht an da kommt jetzt ein
esslöffel olivenöl rhein zum bruder
esslöffel dann verteile ich das mit
silikon finde auch an den rändern hoch
denn das bergwerk bis hoch auf die
ränder gehen sodass hat nissan klebt
und jetzt nehme ich hier diese blätter
ich nehme wie gesagt die große urteil
noch echt relativ lang haltbar und die
kamera kaufen im kühlschrank stellen und
wenn man einfach nur unerwartet besuch
bekommt dann kann man einfach hier sind
direkt aus der pfanne zaubern
und ihr seht es jetzt auch hier die sind
total dünn also ich da kann man glaube
ich durch zeitunglesen und die lege ich
jetzt einfach hier rein und es darf
ruhig so ein bisschen aus der pfanne
rausgucken denn das wenn man später dann
drüber klappen
nun schlägt jetzt so ungefähr zwei drei
schichten rein total total weich also
diese anfangs echt schön diesen stoff
und jetzt gebe ich da von dieser
flüssigkeit rein
dann muss daher gucken dass ihr da immer
bis zum rand untergeht dann noch eine
schicht
da geht man als normal flüssigkeit rüber
und später hilft es einem einfach damit
die flüssigkeit so ein bisschen stoppen
kann und das ganze eben fest zusammen
bleibt und jetzt können wir entweder so
machen dass wir jetzt ungefähr die
hälfte des teigs verbrauchern und dann
die füllung innen in einer schicht
reingeben oder wir verteilen es jetzt
das mache ich jetzt so und verteilt die
füllung jetzt auf drei schichten also
nehme ich jetzt ungefähr so ein drittel
der füllung und gibt es jetzt da rein
jetzt kommen wir da so ein paar
schichten oben drüber und immer jetzt
zwischen jedes stich dieser flüssigkeit
geben
es ist typisch dass man in der türkei
öfters mal so unerwarteten besuch
bekommt das ist es schon so also wir
waren jetzt auch nach dem urlaub mit
meinen eltern und die haben wir jetzt
eine wohnung und wohnen da halt eben ein
paar monate und da war es echt sogar
wirklich jeden abend besuch kommt und
auch mal mittags die kündigen sich dann
gar nicht an sondern klingt einfach und
sagen wir hier bin ich und dann ist man
eben froh wenn man so ein rezept hat was
man einfach kurz schnell machen kann
also das ist wirklich früher war es bei
uns hier in deutschland übrigens auch so
einfach immer besuch gekommen
wahrscheinlich jeden tag
und ja da muss mal kurz was zaubern
das heißt früher heute nicht mehr wie
heute nicht mehr so ich dir ab heute die
türken hier auch so ein bisschen
angedeutet zumindest ich die wir kennen
und dann ruft man halt vorher an gemacht
sondern woche vorher im termin dann
kommt mal irgendwas passt wenn der team
muss man eben verschieden
also ja früher was bei uns hier auch so
wobei bei uns seinen sind immer alle
willkommen egal man bei mir gibt's immer
essen
ich weiß jetzt übrigens hier ab und zu
am rand so die blätter ein und legt sie
einfach mit dazu so dass später nicht zu
viele teigschichten hier außen sind
jetzt kommt bei mir schon die zweite
schicht dran ich einfach das zweite
drittel dazu und verteiltes und dann
fahre ich einfach gleich weiter als ich
gebe dann immer wieder dass eine ganze
schicht drauf nehmen doch aber auch
immer mal wieder von außen hier so
kleine fetzen und gibt hier mit rein und
immer die flüssigkeit mehr dazu das ist
ganz wichtig rasch seit jahrzehnten mit
dem türkischen laden rückt morgen ach
nee ich habe bei meinem anwalt noch in
den türkischen laden geschickt dass er
mir eben paar zutaten holt und
petersilie und so weiter und dann hat
der verkäufer hat gesagt dass eine
kundin dort war und jetzt ihr handy
heraus gezückt und mein video gezeigt
und gesagt sie will genau die produkte
da haben total war ja das war ja gesagt
ja genau sie mich genau dies hier haben
wir warum hatte dies aus der
fernsehsendung gezeigt also richtig cool
und sag nicht du hast mich geschickt ich
bin freiwillig gegangen
das hört sich so an ich habe meinen mann
geschickt und der stadt losgelaufen
wenn du willst dass frauen untereinander
reden
ich hab' ich habe ihn die fenster putzen
lassen
also jetzt noch so ein paar
teigschichten übrig sind etwa 10
aber meine fahne fühlt sich so langsam
als ihr könnt jetzt dann nicht einfach
so ein turm in der pfanne bilden sondern
wenn die pfanne so etwa voll wird müsste
halt aufhören damit und jetzt klappt ich
von außen die blätter hier ein
so hat man nämlich später ein schöner
abschluss
aber vergesst nicht da auch ein bisschen
flüssigkeit rennen zu geben so schwer
dass nämlich trocken
und jetzt nehme ich mir hier gerade noch
so eine tagschicht und ich gebe ich
jetzt darüber weil ich will dass es
obendrauf auch schön aussieht und dann
nehme ich aber hat die ecken weg und wo
die ersten stock so unter den teppich
kehrt
und dem restlichen ottoman da muss ich
jetzt mal wieder für spielmacher und den
rest nämlich jetzt und spielt ihn zu
trüb und dann nehme ich einfach den
löffel und steckt es so bisschen drunter
oder so mit dem löffel rückseite an
drücken
und jetzt gebe ich da noch die restliche
flüssigkeit drüber das kann auch gerne
darunter laufen so einfach damit auch
schön gebräunt wird wer was gleich
anbraten
so sieht jetzt mein pfannenberg vor dem
backen aus und es sieht ziemlich
ungewöhnlichen abgefahren aus so finden
dass zumindest alle hier in der kamera
und jetzt stellen sie sich einfach mal
die die hatte auch mittlere stufe also
bei mir so etwa 45 und es musste zur
ganz langsam backen ich gebe dabei aber
auch den deckel drauf denn dann wird es
so richtig weich und später nämlich den
deckel ab damit wissen knusprig aber
jetzt erst mal von einer seite da müsst
ihr zahlt immer unten dran mal schauen
also nach fünf bis zehn minuten das soll
halt so bisserl goldbraun werte und dann
werden wir gleich zusammen noch wenden
was macht das erst mal ich habe jetzt
den deckel runtergenommen und cookies
hier außen rum dass da eben nichts klebt
müssen wir das ganze wenden ich mein
zeug aus der pfanne raus geht's
natürlich zu schwer
deswegen nimmt ihn jetzt als hilfe so
ein teller einfach eine platte dann
ziehen wir daraus
am besten nicht auf dem herd sondern
eben dran wie jetzt schwierig jetzt
müsste das nämlich hoch nehmen die
pfanne drüber und jetzt einfach zurück
gekleckert aber das macht nichts
und jetzt lassen wir das einfach mal
also etwa 10 10 15 minuten war das jetzt
auf dem herd jetzt lassen wir die andere
seite noch bereuen und hier oben ist
richtig schön knusprig das führen kann
und da gebe ich jetzt den deckel aber
nicht mehr drauf doch die ersten minuten
gibts drauf
die letzten ziffern und mache ich noch
mal weg und wenn es soweit ich sehen uns
gleich wieder zwei weitere 15 minuten
später steht es jetzt so aus und ich
nehme das jetzt mal kurz aus der
zellerau denn ich will es noch einmal
ganz kurz spenden damit die oberseite
jetzt nochmal knusprig wird
da müsste halt aufpassen und das jetzt
kann auch mal eine minute und dann
können wir das hier gleich schon
servieren
jetzt kann ich das aus der pfanne nehmen
und ich gibt es jetzt einfach direkt an
ein brett damit dies durch schneiden
kann
am besten einfach mit messer durch und
das ist auch richtig knusprig wie man
hören kann
und ihnen einfach schön feucht und mit
dem käse richtig schön witzig und ich
gebe es jetzt hier auf seine
servierplatten stadt noch heiß
und ich sage das ganze mit tomaten und
oliven und der morath einfach mal
probieren
aber vorsicht das stand heißt wieso muss
ich mal was probieren weil ich bin ich
nicht stirbt dann probleme wenn es nicht
schlecht des problems nämlich auch und
ich schenk dir noch eine tasse tee
heute ist nur 70 grad heiß aber der
stadt für dich fürs foto
es stimmt am besten mit gabel und messer
ich meine die badener essen ist ja ohne
messer und gabel weil die habe keine
kultur das war nicht ganz böse weil die
schwaben wie er ist mit messer und gabel
schweiz ganz gern für die partnerin mich
schlecht und zwar ist das direct jetzt
von der konsistenz her so dass ich mach
das jetzt mal morata mund voll oben und
unten richtig knusprig und innen drin
einfach richtig schön weich praktisch
ich finde dich autos ist wie sonst übrig
ja so ähnlich
also sagt nämlich noch so eine andere
barrick variante da tut man die juka
blätter erst mal long china kommt es in
ofen und ich hatte richtig feucht und
saftig
das ist das gleiche aber schmeckt so
ähnlich finde ich ein bisschen lassen
der thema und was sie noch dazu nein ich
nicht dass ich fürs foto
dann wissen was ich noch dazu erwähnen
wollte also von der vorbereitung her ist
wirklich sehr wenig zeit als aber
braucht ungefähr zehn bis 15 minuten
vorbereitungszeit aber dann das
auspacken dauert natürlich eine halbe
stunde das ist dann natürlich nicht so
sehr schnell da gibt es schnelle
gerichte wie zum beispiel für ein
aber ich finde man kann jetzt etwas
vorbereitet und dann kann man sich zur
seine gäste setzte und dann einfach mal
allerdings wenden deswegen bei google
auch das fenster wo genau alles möglich
genau das muss ich als macher morath
macht von daher gehört alles klar
das rezept war ziemlich schnell und ihr
dürft das rezept nachlesen auf salehs -
blog.de ich freue mich auf eure
rückmeldungen vor allen dingen könnt ihr
da die füllung austauschen ihr könnt zum
beispiel auch eine hackfleisch die
abfindung machen eine tomaten füllung
egal was vielleicht habt ihr doch
einfach einen andere ideen und könnt ihr
mir einfach mal mitteilen oder man kann
auch den drei machen mir fällt das 21
jawohl
danke auszumachen bis zum nächsten mal
tschüss